comment améliorer la fertilité du sol
sans ajouter d'engrais chimiques c'est
un défi auquel sont confrontés bien des
agriculteurs et une piste de solution se
trouverait peut-être dans le biochar
méconnu au canada le biochar bio pour
biomasse et chars pour charbon c'est un
charbon aux multiples usages en
agriculture comme en horticulture
[Musique]
jean françois lévesque est un semencier
passionnés au jardin déco mène dans la
région de lanaudière au québec son
équipe récolte des semences de près de
300 variétés de fruits de légumes
d'herbe et d'arbres fruitiers au
quintile principalement des plantes
potagères comme les concombres des
tomates et poivrons aubergines oignons
haricots pois les laitues le chou en un
biais s'identifie comme étant gardien
des semences parce que les variétés
qu'on cultive ce sont en grande majorité
des variétés qu'on peut qualifier de
patrimoniale des variétés anciennes pour
améliorer la santé du sol où poussent
ces légumes
jean françois lévesque utilise du
biochar c'est un charbon d'origine
végétale utilisée ailleurs dans le monde
en agriculture et en horticulture il
intègre dans ses champs depuis
maintenant 3
le bia chan a été vraiment pour moi une
révélation
toutes nos actions sont vraiment porté
vers le vivant souple et le vivant à le
renforcer
la première diffusion depuis des années
que je cultive billon qu'ont travaillé
avec les composts des engrais organiques
l'historiquement vous et le compenser la
matière qu'on utilise pour un rang des
sols fertiles mais le composent corps un
inconvénient ski de fond très longtemps
dans le sol le bio champ par contre par
sa haute teneur en carbone peut être
leur pendant des années voire des
siècles
actuellement on a deux acteurs en
production de semences qui ont été je
dirais à 80% inoculé de biochar les
cultures en contenant aussi
bénéficierait grandement de l'ajout du
biochar et déjà on est à même de
constater les effets que ça peut réduire
sur la culture de nos plans jean
françois lévesque constate une
augmentation du rendement des cultures
d'environ 15 à 20 % et ces observations
sont corroborés par les scientifiques
après des années de recherches à
l'université laval 6e à l'air est devenu
expert conseil en biochar la biochar a
un effet direct et indirect sur la
croissance des plantes quand on mène
mais aux chars dans le sol la première
des choses c'est que il a aidé à
structurer le sol donc le sol ce compact
propose donc se joindre paul roll comme
la matière organique donc évite la
compaction ils vont faire la rétention
en eau donc en période de sécheresse les
plantes vont vraiment bien
résister ils vont être plus résiliente
en fait à la sécheresse et ça ce n'est
pas qu'on voit extrêmement grand en
afrique on voit un peu moins au québec
parce que c'est plus pluvieux mes
grands-parents en afrique par exemple on
peut doubler les cultures parce qu'on a
en main du biochar dans le terreau peut
facilement remplacer un la perlite la
vermiculite à 100 pour ça on a fait
plein de tests on essaie des productions
horticoles en peau et ça peut remplacer
une grosse partie de la tour les jardins
de l'écoumène participe à l'avancement
des recherches
il collabore avec des scientifiques
comme sébastien lange de biopterre alors
là on est dans la première année du
projet donc les paramètres qui vont nous
intéresser pour l'instant c'est
croissance biomasse développement du
système racinaire et développement de la
vie au niveau des sols juste à vue de
nez on peut moins que la croissance et
est double pour pour celui qui a reçu la
dose la plus forte versus le témoin si
si on a la parcelle avec du char à ma
droite on à la parcelle 100 bio charge
on voit qu une différence très très très
marquée au niveau de la croissance au
niveau de la biomasse qui était produite
laëticia beaucoup plus grosse ici que là
ce serait que satisfait des résultats à
date
oui ils vont aussi étudier l'effet du
biochar sur le soya et le piment en
rotation parce que les résultats varient
entre autres selon la 2de biochar et
l'espèce planté on peut considérer le
biochar comme étant un penthouse cette
étoile en fait pour ces microorganismes
du sol faut passer au bio char un peu
comme une éponge dans une structure de
carbone et puis c'est plein plein plein
plein plein plein de trous et dans six
trous loto des molécules qu'on appelle
volatiles stage à calais les micro
organismes peuvent aller manger ce
carbone là pour se nourrir et adore
s'installer dans le biochar ils sont
comme à l'abri
hélas les plantes vont faire leurs
interactions leur symbiose alex
micro-organismes la puissa favorise la
croissance végétale
mais chaque biochar est unique il existe
une grande variabilité des effets
bénéfiques en fonction du type de
matières premières et des conditions de
production
il ya vraiment toutes sortes de mets au
genre autant mis aux sharks du sinn que
des matières premières - j'en ai
peut-être 200 ici dans mon bureau
puis j'en ai quelques-uns ici que je
peux vous montrer on a en a qui sont
presque poussé air pour différentes
applications
nous on dans le moule et et le plus
grossier disons
une application que l'ortie coll nous
partons à bécancour à la rencontre de
sylvain bertrand qui dirige une erreur
zim de fabrication de biochar dans le
monde
sa production dépend entièrement des
résidus forestiers qui eux sont
abondants
donc la matière première pour la
fabrication du bio shirts et des résidus
de cuisine de sciages donc ça peut être
de la sueur de bout en bout comme du pin
up ou de bois fera comme comme l'érable
maryse et où le chan dans un premier
temps on va recevoir la biomasse
on voit là broyé on voit la sécher et
ensuite on veut la carbonisés pour avoir
le produit final qui le bioshock la
carbonisation sert à augmenter le taux
de carbone contrairement au charbon de
bois qui nécessite plusieurs jours de
pyrolyse la carbonisation du biochar se
fait en quelques secondes la paix rallye
c'est un procédé qui consiste à chauffer
les matières organiques sans oxygène
on peut en faire un combustible pour
remplacer les combustibles fossiles dans
des centrales thermiques où on peut en
faire un produit à haute teneur en
carbone pour faire la maman des sols ou
pour traiter des sols continue voici le
biochar qu'on produit ici avec en cours
c'est une poudre noire de bois qui vient
carbonisés d'un portrait international
l'usagé ou charles bary énorme
en europe on l'utilisent beaucoup pour
l'alimentation animale puis dans l'est
la production animale dans les lices ya
par exemple les pôles naturellement vont
manger de charme on apprend veut ça ça
les aide avec leurs intestins
on a tout préparé la litière ça leur met
un effet positif sur les animaux 5,8
bon allez je comprends
aussi quand c'est des animaux litière le
biochar protège contre plusieurs
maladies pied et depuis on évite
beaucoup d'antibiotiques à ce moment là
j'en mettrai aussi pour les cayes
j'en mettrai aussi pour les condos russe
notre façon c'est dans les fosses pour
éviter les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre les émissions de gaz
audard à la partie du bio champ je crois
que c'est économiquement viable c'est
une façon de penser c'est une façon de
voir les choses sont dits plus long
terme
ça ramène en fête des cultures beaucoup
plus résilient donc les intrants
chimiques pesticides etc théropodes
facilement exclure ceux de notre plan
comptable il sape retour en photos sur
du long terme des sols fertiles
l'agencé canadienne d'inspection des
aliments vient de modifier la
réglementation sur l'utilisation du
biochar ce qui devrait faciliter son
déploiement au pays